candid truth they faked going to the
moon this is not a conspiracy theory
website the footage doesn't have sound
so it's okay that you guys don't hear it
this is supposed to be like one of the
first footages of space or of stars in
space and this thing is floating up
everybody's watching and there's the
glory look at the stars do you see that
star do you know why that is impossible
because the moon isn't a crescent it's a
whole Moon that's just like shadowed you
shouldn't be able to see a star in the
shadow of the moon or the stars in front
of the moon this is ridiculous like
people actually believe that this is
real but what's awesome is how many
people are waking up you look at the
comments here and people are like ah yes
a star shining through the moon LOL
listen to this about stars when you
looked up at the sky Could you actually
see the stars and the solar Corona in
spite of the glare we were never able to
see stars from the lunar surface or on
the Daylights of the Moon by eye without
looking through the Optics uh I don't
recall during the period of time that we
were photographing the SOA C of what
what stars we could
see I don't remember seeing any we just
saw stars from a balloon but they were
in space they were on the moon and
they're like I don't remember seeing
stars ever I don't remember seeing any
he's like dude come on man stop it's
enough do you see that he gives him a
look and then he's like like like
shrinking back in a seat you seeing
any like come on man so you can see
stars from a balloon but you can't see
stars when you're on the moon there was
a time when the ISS was doing a
supposedly live feed with a school and
somebody said are are you able to see
stars in the ISS and the guy was like oh
yeah you know and uh pretty much all the
time you can see the stars it's it's not
a black void I mean it's black but
there's all kinds of little polka dots
there's all the there's all the stars
there and the cool thing is about you
can see it during the day yeah you can
and there's more than Stars you can see
planets you could see moons you can see
uh the zodiacal lights w we could see
all of the Milky Way all in a single
orbit if I went to the moon I would not
look so depressed people win the
football game and they are so they're
screaming in the locker
room how NASA makes those incredible
highres images of Earth they're saying
that they get the images from low orbit
satellite that takes ribbons of images
and they have to fill those gaps in if
they have satellites why don't they just
go back and take a whole picture of
Earth instead it's literally like an
airplane flying over different parts of
the world taking ribbons of images that
have to be stitched together on this
globe that can be translated into
ribbons of imagery like this and then
into one of these they have to put these
pieces together which means there's
empty spaces between the ribbons that
have to be photo shed in because there's
a very slight Gap in between each orbit
so some of those are painted on it is
photoshopped but it's it's has to be all
these layers are put together to make
that picture of the Blue Marble world
that you all see on your iPhones he
admits it is photoshopped we had to fill
in the gaps because we don't have
technology to go back far enough and
take a picture of Earth and yet people
look at this on their phone and they
will show you that and say look the
Earth is a globe here's the proof we got
a picture of it this is the footage that
Bart got given of them faking halfway to
the Moon look at the pattern that's
cloud coverage there's no way in all the
Earth's history that that cloud
formation could be the same if the Earth
is turning clouds are a vapor that are
just being formed all the time but yet
when you zoom in on this picture of an
astronaut on the moon and look at the
image of Earth it's the same you see
that right you see this it's the same
same cloud formation everything about
this is the same which is why when you
put it inside of Photoshop and start
tweaking with the adjustment layers you
actually see that it's a square if you
take these original images and you put
them in Photoshop we now have the
technology the people have the
technology to put these things in a
program and find out that they're faked
there's no way that a square gets put
around the earth if you're taking a
photograph of Earth from the Moon me as
a graphic designer I know all about this
I use Photoshop constantly if you have
the magic wand tool and you make sure
that the tolerance level is all the way
down it's only going to select that
exact color if that's any different
shade it's going to show you and reveal
it this is another proof that we never
went to the moon that these pictures are
fake this is straight off of NASA's
website it says from A Million Miles
Away NASA's camera shows Moon crossing
face of Earth now look at this this is
the Dark Side of the Moon that we're
seeing this is from I guess a satellite
that's higher than the moon and it
actually caught footage of the moon
going across the Earth what I want you
to notice is the clouds they are not
moving one inch the clouds do not move
at
all in this video of the rotation of the
earth you know how fast clouds move the
website says that these images were
taken between 3:50 p.m. and 8:45 p.m. so
5 hours
of footage and not a single cloud has
moved also notice the sun is behind the
camera which is Illuminating the moon
and yet the Moon is not casting a shadow
on Earth at all this should be a solar
eclipse that's casting the moon's Shadow
on Earth but there's no Shadow when the
moon comes between Earth and the Sun it
casts a shadow on Earth come on man this
is straight from NASA be honest with
yourself this is not real I I'm I'm
looking at different things that make me
know this isn't real there's some weird
like Lighting on the edge of Earth here
this is a perfect circle Neil degros
Tyson says that Earth is pearshaped so
it's not actually a sphere it's an it's
oblate and officially it's an oblate
spheroid that's what we call it it's
slightly wider below the equator than
above the little chubbier little
chubbier yeah chubby is a good way it's
like pear-shaped pearshaped pearshaped
pearshaped pearshaped come on man like
this is not adding up there's no
consistency with space the globe NASA
these physicists this is not a
pear-shaped Earth this is a exact
perfectly round photoshoop circular
Earth and the clouds don't change
formation at all we're going to listen
to Don Pettis say that he'd go to the
moon in a nanc except they destroy that
technology I'd go to the moon in a
nanc the problem is we don't have the
technology to do that anymore we use us
to but we uh destroyed that technology
and it's a painful process to build it
back again it's a painful process dude
we have computers in our pocket we we
are all walking around with computers in
our pocket that can stream video to
thousands of people and back then in
1969 there may have been an Atari like
the computer level back then compared to
now and you're saying
that if you just look at at the moon
lander that thing looks like it was made
by kindergarteners literally it looked
like a science project put together with
shower curtain rods and and gold foil
and a shed there's like a storage shed
on top and it seemed like there was like
three different versions of how they
went to space they got in a rocket that
thing flies up it turns into the lunar
module the thing with legs and feet that
don't have any dust on them when they
land and then somehow when they got in
there that was able to take off and go
back to Earth and land as some kind of
capsule from a parachute dude there's
nothing about this that I'm buying and
and here's these guys saying that they
can't go they can't go higher than lower
Earth orbit right now we only can fly in
Earth orbit that's the farthest that we
can go and this new system that we're
building is going to allow us to go
beyond and hopefully take humans into
the solar system to explore so the Moon
Mars asteroids there's a lot of
destinations that we could go to and
we're building these building block
components in order to allow us to do
that eventually so he just said we can
only go to lower Earth orbit but maybe
one day we could go to places like the
moon and
Mars you mean like we did in 1969 this
is crazy and then here's where he's
saying we need we need to build
shielding on Orion which is this other
Space Capsule thing there's not enough
shielding to get through the Van Allen
radiation belts but they had they would
have had to have gone through the Van
Allen radiation belts to go to the moon
in
1969 and now we're talking about we need
to build shielding that can get humans
and computers onboard computers through
that radiation check this
out my name is Kelly Smith and I work on
navigation and guidance for Orion Orion
is NASA's Next Generation spacecraft
built with versatility in mind it can
take astronauts deeper into space than
we've ever gone before to an asteroid or
even onto Mars for these missions our
has to be one tough spacecraft with
standing high speeds searing
temperatures and extreme
radiation before we can send astronauts
into space on Orion we have to test all
of its systems and there's only one way
to know if we got it right fly it in
space as we get further away from Earth
we'll pass through the Van Allen belts
an area of dangerous
radiation radiation like this could harm
the guidance systems onboard computers
or other electronics on Orion naturally
we have to pass through this danger zone
twice once up and once back we must
solve these challenges before we send
people through this region of space for
this flight it's time to head home he's
literally telling you we can't go
through the Van Allen radiation belts
whether you believe in Van Allen
radiation belts or not I don't anymore I
used to when I first heard about this
stuff but now I believe that there's a
firm firmament either way you can't go
to space and so I think the Van Allen
radiation belts is kind of the deception
to explain why we can't go to space or
why we can't go to the moon but he's
literally saying like this was years
after we went to the moon and he's
saying we are still working on shielding
to be able to get through that those
radiation belts not just for humans but
for even onboard computer so answer me
this how do we have a a little remote
control car on Mars right now that's a
onboard computer and how are we
controlling it from Earth I can't even
get a signal on my phone when I go into
the mountains or on an airplane but we
can control a remote control car from
Earth come on guys we've been duped
here's a a question asked to one of the
astronauts by Bart saell the guy we just
had on listen to how their stories never
line up any ill effects from the Van
Allen radiation
belts no now I'm not sure we went far
enough out to to encounter the Van Allen
radiation belt maybe we did every space
mission in history with humans on board
from both the United States and Soviet
Union from the first in 1961 to the
present has been well below this deadly
radiation field Mercury Gemini soyuz
Skylab the space shuttle all all
maintained altitudes well below 1,000 Mi
all except
Apollo I don't know the distance to the
Van Allen radiation belt and if we did
it wasn't a problem the belts are 1,000
miles to 25,000 Mi above the Earth we
then we went right out through them no
effects on yourselves didn't even know
it I don't think anybody well maybe
somebody said you went through the
radiation Bell but we didn't feel it
inside you went to the moon and you
don't you had to go through months of
training and going through all these
different things and you don't even know
where the vanel and radiation belts are
like you weren't primed for that and
prepped like hey now when you get this
far up you might feel a little
uncomfortable because there's severe
bands of radiation that you're going to
be going through and he's like no we we
must have went right through it I I
didn't even know about it two astronauts
were asked is the the engine is it loud
this is what they said two conflicting
stories is the engine loud as you're
descending well the engine is very loud
it's very difficult to tell the
difference between feeling sound and
hearing sound but yes it's loud when you
were in it you couldn't hear it in the
vacuum of space if you asked two people
hey you both were at that party last
night was the music loud and one person
was like oh yeah it was very loud the
other person was like I don't know I
couldn't hear it you would be like
what's going on were you guys really
both at that party or not
I mean this is this is damning evidence
these are liars these people are lying
now when Buzz Aldren was asked why
haven't we been to the Moon in such a
long time he has a very interesting
answer check this out why has nobody
been to the Moon in such a long
time that's
not an 8-year-old's
question that's my
question I want to know but I think I
know cuz we didn't go there
and and that's the way it happened and
and if it didn't happen it's nice to
know why it didn't happen so okay uh
that's just the craziest answer ever
there's no like people can say context
whatever go look it up it's like a 17
minute long video This Girl's dad I'm
sure uh asked her to ask him these
questions and that's why he gives like a
nervous laugh when he goes oh that's not
an eight-year-old question the dad's
like but then he's saying that's my
question go watch it there's no context
that will make what he said make make
sense if he literally went to the moon
no context can explain what he just said
why has nobody been to the Moon in such
a long time cuz we didn't cuz we didn't
cuz we didn't
go there
and and that's the way it happened and
and if it didn't happen it's nice to
know why it didn't happen so it would be
nice to know why it didn't happen I want
to know now check this out this is crazy
so George Bush is being pushed through
the Space Center and there's footage
live quote unquote live footage from the
ISS going on in the background what do
you see that's interesting in the
background I see a a blue screen with a
grid on it that same guy is right here
showing you how you can play with a
bubble of water in space now why is the
background blue with a grid on it and
he's got a green ball this is special
effects happening right that he got
caught right there on television while
they're pushing George Bush this blue
grid is how they do live compositing
live keying because the camera and the
and the software can pick up on that
grid and even if the camera moves the
background moves with it so that you
look like you're in the environment and
this is live
keying this is exactly what they're
doing the ISS has been there's been so
many things that have shown that the ISS
is Faking it whether it's harness wires
or green screen glitches or bubbles in
space or hairsprayed hair instead of it
flowing around and we're going to look
at some of that stuff I'm going to show
you these clips that I put together and
uh W you just be honest with yourself
while you're watching these clips um you
see this guy doing a back flip and
people are grabbing wires behind him
grabbing his wire on his leg this guy he
actually
falls halfway through his
flip um this guy he he tries to bend
down and can only go so far this guy I
can't even do a back flip in zero
g and this lady grabs a wire as she
stands up now I'm going to show you all
these compar them side by side look this
guy's definitely struggling with a
harness wire on the left this guy on the
right's grabbing a cord that you can see
attached to his pants and the guy in the
background is swatting at a a wire he's
trying to
grab here the guy on the left Falls
halfway through his flip and on the
right this guy is lunging to do a back
flip and if this was zero g he would
just continue to go on but he
doesn't um here on the left we see this
lady grab a wire as she stands up or
she's just grabbing nothing maybe I
don't know on the right this guy bends
down but is stopped by resistance and
you see his shirt lift up in the
back so I mean you just have to be
honest with yourself is this zero g is
this really really the ISS going on uh
these are scenes from the movie called
life it's about the ISS and you can see
how they're floating around with
harnesses I think this is how they're
doing
it uh this lady's hair is just stiff as
a board standing straight up and that's
her proof that they're on the
ISS this lady's hair is bouncing right
back in place as she bends down I've
reversed it back and forth so you can
see how she moves her head forward and
instead of her hair freely flowing
forward bounces back in place same with
this Medusa chick here um she's
definitely in a zero g plane because
she's floating around but her hair is
hairsprayed stiff now if you're just
going to keep your hair out of your way
I would pull it back in a
ponytail but uh she's got it stiff now
this is what your hair would do in zero
g freely move not stiff as a board like
we see on the right here this is hair
spray this looks exactly like what we
see on the
ISS now sometimes we do see hair moving
freely on the ISS when it's a uh an
edited shot you know just little Clips
but if there's any long periods of shots
or live they definitely do the hairspray
so you can't tell when the plane levels
out but look at this hair freely
flowing on the ISS so both of these are
from the ISS but their hair is doing
completely different things
so U you come up with your own
conclusion
here but this is how I expect people to
fly around on the ISS just cork screwing
and going all crazy but they always just
do this back flip or this front flip
this stiff flip and then gravity hits
boom
wh there's that gravity there's no
consist see I don't know I don't
understand why people will choose to
believe this lie when they can see it
right there inside by-side comparisons
that there's zero consistency This Is A
Lie they are caught red-handed there's
evidence proof video proof that they're
lying this technology is not difficult
people act like there's no way you can
fake this stuff and it's very simple if
you've ever watched a movie even as far
back as 2001 A Space Odyssey that was a
year before the moon landing happened
and they were floating around in space
imagine what we can do now with the
technology we have now this is one of
the first footages of a spacewalk where
he comes out of the spaceship watch that
head
turn watch it turn and look at the
camera as he waves I'm going to show you
again he turns his head and waves how
can an astronaut turn his head does an
astronaut's helmet turn no an
astronaut's helmet does not turn AI is
scouring the internet and getting the
best answer for your question does an
astronaut's helmet turn no but we just
saw it happen so this is where NASA
trains astronauts before they can go to
space I'm here with Terry Dunn you're
the training operations manager and
Terry we're in front of a space suit
right this is the extra vehicular
Mobility unit or emu as we call it and
it's the space suit that astronauts wear
for space walks either the space shuttle
back in those days or the space station
now and so this has been used this is a
design that's been used for decades
right it's essentially unchanged for the
past 40 years he said it was used for
space walks he said it was unchanged for
decades listen to what he says design
that's been used for decades right it's
essentially unchanged for the past 40
years this right here this astronaut
space suit is the same model that has
been used for decades nothing's changed
listen and this is a very rigid suit
like there's not a lot of mobility in
here right the upper part that they call
it the hard upper torso for a reason
it's um really a hard shell and despite
the obvious Comfort level of that
there's a reason for it and you've got
to have all these different things the
life support system the controls for the
suit your tools all have to be rigidly
mounted so you need that hard shell to
be able to do that you need that hard
shell that rigidness at the top okay we
we're getting a little bit closer but
here is the nail in the coffin and with
the helmet on the helmet doesn't turn
when the astronaut's head turns that's
right your field of view is very limited
the helmet doesn't turn when the
astronaut's head turns that's right your
field of view is very limited so is your
situational awareness and so you can
basically look almost all the way to
your right and left and then you need to
be able to look down as well correct so
if you need to see beyond those views
you're turning your whole torso like
you're in traction you're turning your
whole torso he's saying the helmet
doesn't move and this is newer this is
like a newer model he could have said
yeah back in the day you know we didn't
have the technology to make your head
move but now we do no he's saying this
model the helmet doesn't move and it's
the same unchanged model that we've used
for decades on spacewalks we're building
the whole evidence the whole evidence is
what we saw was footage of a spacewalk
we saw a helmet turn it looked like
claymation the Earth that wasn't
spinning 1,000 M an hour they're saying
this is the
unchanged astronaut suit and it doesn't
turn the helmet does not turn you have
to turn your whole body come on are we
going to lie to
ourselves are we going to continue to
believe this fairy tale just because
what we think it's fun or we don't want
to believe that we've been lied to why
are we still believing this so how much
did the original moon buggy cost I just
think this is interesting the original
moon buggy also known as the lunar
roving vehicle had an initial contract
cost of1 million $19 million for that
thing but due to cost overruns the final
price reached $38
million $38 million you want to see what
that looks
like that's 38 million guys that
seriously looks like two lawn chairs on
a on a door with wheels attached to it
how can that cost $38
million
$38 million guys and that was back in
1969 come on dude1 1969 $38 million for
a doom buggy and not even a really nice
one this is insane guys so the
astronauts got back inside the the moon
lander and they're going back home to
Earth
who is recording
this they left a cameraman they left a
cameraman on the moon just for this shot
and it's not just a it's not like okay
they left a camera big deal we left a c
cameras are very expensive it had the
footage in it how do we get how do we
even get this footage how are they live
streaming in
1969 dude I'm starting to like just dude
there's nothing about this that makes
sense how was astronauts live streaming
in
1969 when every phone had a cord
attached to the wall there was nothing
Wireless oh my goodness dude how did how
did anybody believe this look at
this the camera pans up it's not just a
camera left on a
tripod and like I was saying the footage
would have had the the camera would have
had the footage in it unless they're
somehow live streaming and I guess they
did I guess somehow they at least had a
public fooled that you could live stream
from the moon in 1969 with VHS cam
quarters and they left someone on the
moon to record the the flight back home
oh my goodness guys oh we're so gullible
sometimes I hope this was I opening for
you guys like if you were never a
skeptic if you never thought about this
maybe the wheels are turning if you had
heard about it but thought it was
nonsense of course we went to the moon I
pray that something shown here was like
H maybe I need to look into this more
but I just thank you guys for being here
I love talking about these topics the
truth will set you free that's what
we're here for the candid truth we want
to talk about the truth and we want to
get candid with it I hope you guys enjoy
this if you did please give it a thumbs
up it really helps get this video out
into the algorithm so more people can
see it if you've never subscribed to to
this Channel please take a moment and
hit that little subscribe button press
the little bell icon so you won't miss
another episode like this and if you
would like to donate to this ministry we
have ways of doing that through cash app
vinmo zel if you go to candid truth.org
you can click the Donate button and
donate through PayPal and it's because
of you guys that we can even continue to
do this ministry and because of that
we'll see you next time I love you guys
God bless candid truth
[Music]